Salut ! Aujourd'hui on est mercredi, c'est le jour de l'astuce du mercredi
Comme vous pouvez le constater il est 14h48, je dois partir à 16h de chez moi, donc je suis grave grave à la bourre
Pour décider quelle vidéo j'allais faire, j'ai pris ce matin
le cahier à idées : le cahier qui comporte les idées que vous me donnez
souvent en commentaire sur YouTube et
que je note précieusement ici.
Mon précieux cahier... (Voix Golum)
Ca m'a permis de trouver le thème de cette vidéo là,
et aussi le thème du Master Class' de samedi.
Je vous tease je vous le dis à la fin, je pense vraiment que ça va vous plaire.
Mardi vous le saviez il y avait mon plateau "Hallucinations collectives et autres illusions fantastiques".
Eh bien aujourd'hui je vais vous parler d'illusions.
Vous allez vous faire, halluciner, vous même, grâce à des illusions soit sensorielles, soit d'optique, soit autres.
5 illusions donc pour ce mercredi.
La première illusion : c'est quelque chose que vous allez faire à vous même.
Vous même tout seul, ça va être dans votre tête à vous
Ca s'appelle l'apparition de la saucisse.
Je vais vous aider à faire apparaître une saucisse qui n'existe pas.
Alors ça peut être une knacki ball ça peut être une saucisse de bonne taille, ça va être à vous d'en décider.
Pour ça vous allez illusionner vos yeux et votre cerveau
et c'est pas très compliqué.
Vous mettez un doigt comme ça,  l'autre doigt comme ça et vous les rapprochez
relativement proches.
Et vous allez utiliser ce qu'on appelle la vision lointaine.
Vous allez regarder plus loin.
C'est comme si je mettais ma main là et que je cherchais à regarder les livres qu'il y a derrière
Vous savez on a la vision qui se trouble, qui se dédouble un petit peu à ce moment là :
c'est exactement ce qu'on recherche.
Une fois que vous avez placé vos doigts et que vous regardez le lointain,
que vous regardez derrière, vous allez bouger un petit peu les doigts,
jusqu'à temps que vous voyiez apparaître une saucisse.
Une saucisse qui flotte en l'air. Une saucisse qui est reliée à rien. C'est quand même fou.
Voilà moi à cette distance j'ai la saucisse
Alors ouais c'est une saucisse de bonne taille .
Si j'écarte un petit peu mes doigts forcément ça devient une petite knacki ball,
et si je les rapproche ça fais agrandir la saucisse.
Je peux aussi bouger d'avant en arrière
Voilà vous vous auto-illusionnez, vous vous auto-bluffez,
mais je trouve ça très drôle à faire.
Ca me fait quand même particulièrement rire de vous faire une vidéo à base de saucisse.
La deuxième illusion elle est très rigolote elle va jouer sur la persistance rétinienne.
Je vais vous faire voir une image maintenant.
Comme vous pouvez le constater c'est l'image de mon affiche, de mon spectacle :
celui qui est en tournée actuellement.
Vous allez fixer le point rouge que j'ai mis sur mon affiche. Vous le fixez, vous ne le lâchez pas des yeux pour l'instant
Vous ne clignez pas si possible.
Vous ne bougez pas les yeux, vous fixez ce point rouge.
Tout le temps ce point rouge, vous ne bougez pas,
vous le fixez c'est bien normal.
Et je claque des doigts
*claque*
Et je change d'affiche !
Vous voyez toutes ces belles couleurs ?
Et bien si vous bougez les yeux vous ne les verrez plus,
vous allez avoir l'impression que l'affiche en noir et blanc.
Parce que oui oui l'affiche était en noir et blanc !
Vous pouvez revenir en arrière pour le vérifier :
c'est ce qu'on appelle la persistance rétinienne.
Vous avez joué au photographe en développant vous même mon affiche !
Troisième astuce : Cascades
Vous allez de nouveau vous auto-illusionner, vous auto-bluffer,
vous auto-optiquer, tous ce que vous voulez mais avec un autre sens :
celui du toucher.
Vous devez prendre une petit objet rond, dans l'idéal une bille.
On a pas toujours une bille chez soi.
Moi j'ai essayé avec un dé ça fonctionne très très bien.
C'est une bille carré avec des chiffres dessus en fait.
Mais si vous avez une bille ou quelque chose de sphérique en fait, et de pas trop grand,
ça sera beaucoup mieux pour le faire je vous le recommande c'est encore plus bluffant.
Pour cette troisième astuce auto-illusionnante vous mettez vos doigts comme ceci,
vous passez un doigt l'un sur l'autre et vous allez poser vos doigts sur l'objet.
L'idée c'est de mettre en contact le bout des doigts sur la surface de l'objet.
Vous faites comme ça et vous regardez à côté.
Vous commencez à bouger un petit peu les doigts sur la surface.
C'est important que les 2 bouts de doigts soit toujours en contact en même temps avec la surface,
et plus vous allez appuyer et bouger un petit peu,
juste comme ça,
plus vous allez avoir la sensation qu'il y a 2 objets sous vos doigts :
2 objets distinct, comme si y avait un vide entre vos doigts.
Alors, avec le dé, moi j'ai l'impression d'avoir un petit peu 2 dés.
En plus j'avais pas pensé à ça mais c'est tout à fait contradictoire avec l'information de l'autre main
qui elle ne sent qu'un seule objet.
C'est très drôle à faire
Je le fais sur le 3 mais vous pouvez le faire sur un autre chiffre hein ça marche très bien aussi,
et si vous le faites avec une bille alors là c'est formidable parce que vous pouvez la faire rouler comme ça et l'illusion elle est terrible,
vous avez l'impression, la sensation d'avoir 2 billes au bout des doigts.
Même si vous regardez après, ça fait pas perdre la sensation
C'est vraiment une astuce auto-illusionnante, auto-bluffante.
Quatrième astuuuce : je crois que je commence à craquer
Je vais vous aider à faire disparaître un point ce que vous voulez en fait.
Prenez une feuille, prenez un stylo, un marqueur
peu importe, et vous faites un point de chaque côté de la feuille. Les 2 points doivent être espacés d'environ 6,5-7 cm
il y a 2 écoles.
Ensuite vous placez cette feuille devant vos yeux.
Vous fermez l’œil gauche et avec l’œil droit vous regardez uniquement le point gauche que vous avez fait.
Tout en faisant ça vous allez approcher la feuille devant vous.
Et à un moment très précis qui se situe à peu près à 15 cm entre la feuille et votre visage,
le point qui est à droite va disparaître.
Vous allez plus le voir du tout.
Notez aussi que ça marche à l'inverse :
c'est à dire que si vous fermez l'oeil droit
et que vous gardez l'oeil gauche ouvert, et qu'avec l'oeil gauche vous regardez le point droit en approchant...
Voilà. Là exactement à ce moment là je vois plus le point.
Si vous voulez on se le fait en direct.
Je vous mets ça devant, voilà. Vous fermez votre œil gauche et avec votre œil droit vous regardez uniquement le point de gauche.
Vous approchez... Vous approchez le nez de l'écran... Allez-y approchez le nez de l'écran, n'ayez pas peur. Approchez !
Et à un moment très précis en faisant lentement,
vous allez constater que le point de droite va disparaître.
Approchez... Approchez... Approchez...
AHHHH !!! Désolé j'ai pas pu m'empêcher.
Ca fonctionne grâce à un point qu'on connais bien en fait qui s'appelle le point aveugle.
C'est l'endroit précis dans l’œil où il y a pas de photo-récepteur
En fait il y en a pas parce que c'est comme un petit trou en fait où passent tous les vaisseaux sanguins et le nerf optique.
Donc forcément le cerveau comble avec ce qu'il se souvient de l'image, ce qui est cohérent. En fait notre cerveau nous ment à ce moment là,
c'est très drôle parce qu'on s'en rend pas compte.
Et on va terminer avec deux illusions d'optique:  une sur le mouvement et une autre sur la perception.
Elles ne sont pas de moi, elles sont du Professeur Kitaoka de l'université de Kyoto.
La première c'est celle-ci regardez-la bien.
Je vous le dit... rien ne bouge !
Et si vous ne me croyez pas vous mettez Pause et vous allez voir que ça continue de bouger quand même pour vous.
Et la deuxième je la trouve particulièrement bluffante,
c'est à dire que... même moi qui la connait j'ai été obligé... *rire*... je vous jure que c'est vrai... de vérifier à la règle.
Regardez bien cette image :
vous pouvez vérifier... et l'imprimer... toutes les lignes sont droites et parallèles entre elles.
Toutes les lignes de ce dessin sont droites et parallèles, il n'y a pas de courbes, il y a pas de choses comme ça.
Bravo Professeur Kitaoka !
Voilà c'était l'astuce du mercredi. Je reste pas beaucoup plus longtemps avec vous parce qu'il faut que je la monte et que je la mette en ligne.
J'ai quand même une annonce le Master Class' que je vais faire samedi c'est
par rapport à des commentaires que j'ai eu une bonne vingtaine de fois je crois sur les vidéos YouTube :
je vais vous apprendre à compter les cartes aux black-jack.
Voilà on va faire un Master Class' de 10-15 min là dessus,
et à la fin vous saurez toutes les techniques, toute la méthodologie pour pouvoir compter les cartes
sur le jeu du black jack
Demain, je lance la première vidéo en mode "Je parle de ce que je veux"
Euh vendredi je crois que je tourne avec Karim Duval une vidéo
C'est la première fois que je vous annonce la semaine. Ben voilà je suis parti pour vous l'annoncez.
Samedi je viens de vous le dire et dimanche je ne sais pas encore ce que je ferai comme explication de la semaine.
Si cette vidéo vous a plu, n'hésitez pas : un pouce en l'air,
un petit partage et surtout abonnez-vous à la chaîne, c'est très très important
Abonnez-vous, on est de plus en plus nombreux et ça c'est grâce à vos partages
C'est vraiment cool. Objectif 2500 abonnés.
A 2500 abonnés, on se fait un live ensemble durant 2-3 heures je mets ça en place,
et j'ai vraiment hâte que ça arrive. Donc abonnez-vous et emmenez vos potes.
On se retrouve demain pour le prochain Mental Vlog. CIAO !